Hey Kathy, Changmin, how are you guys doing?
Did you enjoy the holiday?
Hi Susie. Yes, I had a great time. I recharged my batteries.
Yes, I enjoyed the holiday, too, I guess, but I'm a bit tired.
You don't sound very convincing there, and you look tired.
Why didn't you take a rest during the weekend?
I did rest.
It's just that I had planned to get a lot of work done over the holiday,...
...but I ended up doing nothing.
What kind of work did you want to do?
Well, I have a big project due for my computer science class.
I see what you mean, but I don't think you should worry too much about it.
Susie's right.
I wish you had done it before, but there's still plenty of time left in this semester.
Yes, but I really think I should have gotten more work done.